if the cubs uniforms look a little bit
different
it's their city connect jerseys that
they're debuting tonight
part of their partnership with nike the
jerseys are a nod to the second city
symbolism the cubs will celebrate the
uniqueness of chicago's 77 neighborhoods
by highlighting local organizations and
youth programs making an impact in their
community kyle hendricks on the mound he
has been a very hot pitcher of late
winning his last five starts not
overpowering 86-87 he's got to be
spot-on with his command and he has to
get the change-up going especially
against the lefties for the cardinals
tommy edmund leads it off he's a
left-handed batter swinging a miss on a
change-up and that's out number one and
that has been his bread and butter here
is dylan carlson stepping in out in
front of that one is carlson and out in
first is dylan
two down
schmidt is
seven 11-32-7 and two runs batted in
facing hendricks over the years bouncing
ball to short charging gloving bias
comes up throwing gets him one two three
hendrix makes it look easy after a half
inning so right-hander john gant this
guy's got great stuff he's got that
vulcan change if he gets ahead of you
the problem the walks that has got to be
disconcerting and if he can get ahead of
you he can be filthy it's just trying to
get ahead of hitters cubs lead off
batter will be jack peterson is grounded
right into the teeth of the defense as
arnado was swung well to his left hit
right at him one down now chris bryant
bryant old for his last eight against
gann but he has been on during that
stretch with a couple of walks he's
skied into pretty shallow center carlson
has out number two two outs and here's
javier baez change up swung on and
missed baez strikes out and gant works a
one two three first top of the second
inning with the cleanup batter nolan
arnotto facing veteran kyle hendricks
arnotto's seven for 27 with two homers
and three rbis facing hendricks a long
drive to left field that's it well and
it is gone
a line drive into the bleachers arenado
gives the cardinals a one nothing lead
in the second he's got four wins gant
the only major league starter issuing
six or more walks per nine innings
pitched so he has been dodging bullets
but he also doesn't give up home runs
cubs still looking for their first hit
of the game ian happ the batters fly
ball left center field and deep that
goes carlson it's got a chance gone
half a two run homer cubs lead two to
one that's the danger that john gayle
walks right three straight walks and
four of the last five hitters have found
bases on boss kent has walked the bases
loaded and now john peterson can do some
real damage in this particular at-bat
sticks the bat out trying to dump it
into left center this is pot
on a really good play by paul deyoung
got a good jump made the catch rather
easily
and the bases will stay loaded with two
down but it's not over yet because chris
bryant is coming up low ball four
it chases in a run cubs lead three to
one and that will be it for gans
five walks in the inning now the number
nine man to bat in the inning xavier
baez bias lines the base it into left
center field one runners in hubs lead
four to one you cannot hit a ball much
harder than baez just did and now rizzo
this one hits rizzo to force home
another run and it's five to one here in
the second and here is wilson
up conference side [ __ ] in the inning
and de young
has it to end a long bottom of the
second
lead 5-1 but just keep in mind this is a
cubs cardinals game a team in red yeah
don't count them out yet folks did high
and deep to left field that's back and
it's gone a long home run for paul
deyoung welcome back cardinals second
home run of the game and it's now five
to two chicago cardinals with another
base runner woodford will trot on down
to second base carlson makes his way
towards first base and paul goldschmidt
will back 3-2 pitch
that's off the end of the bat into right
center half is there makes the grab
runners stay put two on two out
and a big out as hendricks wins that
battle with goldschmidt
arnado drove in three runs yesterday why
not drive in three with one swing here
and
make it a four rbi day bouncing ball
sharply to short backhanded by bios
throws to second there's the force
that's the out good play the inning
comes to an end so the damage is minimal
cub still with a three-run lead here in
the third and the batter is sergio
alcantra here's one into right
absolutely crushed and gone
now
gets number two on the year and sergio
gives the cubs their four-run lead back
jack peterson top of the order for the
cubs just three cubs hits in this game
but five walks issued a high fly ball to
left center back at the wall it's gone
home run peterson
my
oman ball game here in the fourth
the veteran left-hander andrew miller
takes over for seth ellidge contreras
hits a hot shot up the middle diving
play by de young he gets to his feet
throws him out one pitch one out for
miller with a little help from paul
deyoung up the middle of the infield
diving stopped to his left and paul de
young proving that the rib injury is
behind him as homer tonight and made a
nice play here to start the fifth look
out there and you say man hendricks
hasn't been great but he's two runs on
two solo home runs a lot of soft contact
from the cardinals
and once those mechanics clicked he has
been lights out for the cubs and leading
this rotation that's ten straight
retired by hendrix he's settled in
nicely he's doing exactly what the cubs
needed him to do yes he gave up the two
home runs but again he's into the sixth
inning he's guide on the infield
baez to his right near the line it is a
one two three inning for hendricks cubs
have a man on cubs leads seven to two
bottom of the seventh inning and the
batter is wilson contreras runner goes
swinging a miss throw down and
save a stolen base
for rizzo
and they're going to ask for a another
look at that it appears
are you kidding me
with the pick
from his knees and then an absolutely
perfect throw and he's out molina
smiling out at rizzo as it was saying no
no you have to wait till another time to
steal a bag when i'm catching
seven two ball game bases loaded two out
and mundo sosa coming up against craig
kimbrell with a tying run in the on deck
circle this is the same chance for
kimbrell hard hit right at wisdom
gathers throws and got it
cubs win it a final of 7-2
[Applause]